let's talk about this outfit who are you
wearing you I am blessed by Jean Paul
Gautier today and I'm so excited to be
here thanks blessed by jean-paul Goude
yes we are I love it how are you feeling
being a tie huh um it's my first time
here absolutely excited and the category
that I'm nominated best breakout solo
that is a once-in-a-lifetime moment I am
excited to be here with such incredible
women in the category and all around
including you today including you not
John Paul not in the scene but how do
you feel about getting that recognition
though it has to feel like I'm cementing
what I've been working so hard I it's
such an honor to be nominated alongside
incredible woman who shared the same
story of togetherness and also now
embracing individuality by staying
together and being together and it's
real yeah and I hope that this moment
inspires more women to empower one
another and also like good that kpop is
getting a lot of moments in the last pot
I think that's why I'm shaking kpop is a
moment that my fans and the fans have
came together all around the world to
vote has been just mind-blowing and more
more left to kpop I mean do you talk to
some of your fellow artists in that
world about like oh my God we're going
global like it's all getting mainstream
it's all happening absolutely I mean I
just talked to my girls in Girls
Generation this morning I was like I'm
up for like a new artist to word and
just everything that's going on in kpop
I'm just so happy to be a part of and
I'm happy to be here what about you know
best
break out nomination tonight what goals
you setting for yourself what do you
wanna do from here I just hope this
moment inspires more women to empower
one another that togetherness is what
makes you really break out so let us all
break out
[Music]